Film Courage: I know you've been a big proponent of
writers asking questions questions
concerning anything about their career
or whatever. But why would a writer be
afraid to ask questions?
Kathie Fong Yoneda: I think people in general sometimes are
afraid to ask questions for whatever
reason. A lot of times and I and I used
to be this way too when I was a kid I
used to think well if I asked a question
people are going to think I'm stupid or
that I you know why would I ask the
court I must not know what I'm doing and
it's the same I think the older we get
well a lot of times you know how many of
you out there you know have been afraid
to ask their boss you know quite a
question because you don't know what
they're gonna say are they gonna think
you're stupid or you don't know what
you're doing I think sometimes asking
questions if you know and you if
especially if you're asking them and you
phrase it in a way that that is asking
for advice I think then people love it
that people like being asked for advice
so I always believe there's something I
call the open-ended question the
open-ended question is is saying
something in a way where you are not
asking for a question that has a
yes-or-no answer you want to get
information and this is especially
helpful when you maybe have won an
interview with somebody you know like if
you're pitching and you maybe have
finished your pitch and they have
finished giving you feedback and if they
say oh do you have any other questions
that's the perfect time for an
open-ended question such as what are
some of the genres that you guys are
interested in doing in the future you
know that's not a yes or no answer and
it's getting valuable information so
that you know oh okay you know if they
say oh well you're we're looking for an
action piece or something like that or
I'm looking for a romance novel or
something you know if you have something
like that that's a perfect way for you
to then say oh you know I've got a I've
got a romantic comedy and and you can do
a logline on it and you know it's it's
halfway done and you know would you be
interested in taking a look at it one I
mean it's a way of breaking the ice -
and open
your conversation so an open-ended
question is just the most amazing thing
it's not asking something that's oh well
do you like this or not that's yes or no
you know you're asking for their advice
other quite other kinds of examples of
open-ended questions what do you think
about that's all I got
you know you mentioned such and such as
as being a problem can you can you give
me some examples of this
so you haven't better idea you're
extending the one you're extending the
conversation to you're gathering more
information and three you're
establishing a relationship a back and
forth relationship they're going to
remember they are more likely to
remember that conversation with you
should you contact them later you know
and especially if you do a little
thank-you note that says you know that
says dear so-and-so thank you so much
for taking the time to answer my
questions I really enjoyed talking with
you and about you know such and such as
mentioned I have a I finally finished my
romantic my romance novel or my romance
comedy or whatever and here's a you know
I meant I'm attaching a little short
paragraph about it and if you think this
is of interest
I mean you've started now a relationship
how successful that relationship is I'm
not sure but at least you that's the way
you start a relationship and that's how
you you know if by answering and asking
open-ended questions within your own
writers group as well that's where I say
start to practice there first
then you can start using it on things
like when you go to pitch fest or when
you go to meet with them maybe you know
somebody who's who's a producer or an
agent or something so that's you know to
me that's that's the best way to start
getting your your work out there and
getting yourself used to it is asking
questions yeah and I think it indicates
interest too and definitely you know
because if someone says well degree do
you have any questions
me no I don't think so then you think oh
they're not they're done they want to
leave but if you show yes I do it shows
that this is something you want to
commit time to you're interested you're
willing you're open
yeah but the open-ended question it's
something I learned very early because I
was a journalism major and when you
interview people you don't want to just
get a yes or no answer so I it's
something that has worked really really
well for me and it's worked really well
for my clients too because they it's
such a simple thing but you need to kind
of practice it a little bit and it does
it shows interest it also when you ask
people for their advice people even a
boss likes to be asked for his advice
and I don't I think it's just the way
that you that you ask it and it's
surprising how the results that you
might get
you